ich habe mich einfach beworben
zwei tage nach dem vorstellungsgespräch
an die sich gemeldet und wollten wissen
wir nicht anfangen kann
das freut mich für dich und das machst
du da jetzt karriere
wer stellen produktlösungen für digitale
medien kampagnen apps websites web
format usw also auch eine agentur
sag mal kannst du brückmann medien er
klar an den kommt zu einer branche nicht
vorbei und da gleich eine präsentation
und wenn wir diesen auftrag bekommen
dann hättet ihr einen dicken fisch an
guten morgen guten morgen ich hätte gern
ein latte macchiato und für dich du
einen schalter bitte gerne danke
flotte ich muss los
wohin denn ich muss zur uni ich dachte
du hast heute keine vorlesung
lerngruppen
ich glaube mich gleich mit ein paar
community ich dachte habt alle klausuren
schon geschrieben oder das ist unser
abschluss treffen
ich habe mich doch alle gäste zum
abschlusstreffen okay ich bin nicht mehr
dran
500 meter geradeaus links abbiegen und
dann die dritte straße rechts der
taxifahrer start mich an sagt jung
der taxifahrer manche sachen verlernt
man ein taxifahrer immer taxifahrer
apropos schlecht bezahlte berufe wie
privat mit joe ach du die band ist
gerade super erfolgreich stell dir vor
mittlerweile kennt man sie sogar in
brasilien
ehrlich gesagt ich hab mir auch mal was
von denen gekauft du ja seid ihr noch
zusammen ja klar wir haben selber wie
sieht dein privatleben so aus dass seine
freundin
ich bin sozusagen kurz davor schon 15
misty kam zu spät und dann habe ich den
termin wird mein media ist hier links um
die ecke wollen wir uns nach dem treffen
ist zurzeit der klar ruf einfach durch
wenn du fertig bist
hast du noch deine alte hatten ja ruft
einfach durch und es los viel erfolg
danke
witt ist doch nicht sein oder
was sind deine sprache kam es ging nur
dosen in kühlschrank eine einsame
flasche ketchup und die tier ist einzig
halbwegs frische partie gefunden habe
was ist da erwartet
interessant aus hier alex events köln
ich habe hier gleich einen termin
nur die ruhe du schaffst das
ganz lassen die mich absichtlich warten
was machst du denn hier
ich habe einen termin mit frau kocher
santos von alex events köln dass sie
nehme ich an
ich bin mark braun herzlich willkommen
bei brück mit media